we are live right now I'm just going to
wait a second for people to connect
sending out a tweet saying that I'm live
etc etc all of that stuff going to be
talking about what am I going to be
talking about I will be following up a
lot of questions in the aftermath of our
story about the entire pedophilia Milo
you Napoles thing and I'm going to talk
about that a little bit and and I have
some more thoughts and a lot of it
relates to this concept of identity
politics etc which I will be dealing
with also will preview some of what's
happening on tomorrow's program we'll
take some questions from the chat super
chat is enabled if people want to use it
also we'll be doing live shoutouts and
thank-yous to everybody who signs up at
david pakman.com slash membership during
the live stream and I want to talk about
a little bit about what's going on on
reddit so there's kind of a lot going on
so since we went on today
Mylo innopolis has indeed resigned from
his position at Breitbart and you know
sort of expected it seemed kind of
obvious that maybe at this point this
was even too much for Breitbart him for
a group of people who haven't been
following it sort of I call him all
right darling although some people have
been writing in and saying Milo's not
really alt write in any case my
innopolis has sort of been the darling
of the alt-right and a big trump
supporter and his big thing has been
because of his identity as a as a gay
man who date's black men but is still a
conservative who likes Trump his thing
has been oh the left can't write me off
or play identity politics with me in the
way that they can with with some other
people and of course the problem with
this is that Milo's entire thing his
entire shtick was also based on identity
politics right because my Logan appleís
was not saying anything even remotely
unique
interesting what was interesting about
it to the right was because of his
identity and it's sort of is I don't
know if it's a double standard or
hypocrisy or just sort of ironic that
someone who denounces identity politics
in in the way that he sees the left
doing it was only popular because of
identity politics now I'm talking kind
of in the past tense but I don't
necessarily think that it's over for
Milo in fact it's possible it's possible
that he will be able to turn this entire
bad press thing around and play up the
victim card and maybe even turn turn
this around into something more I want
to point out something else
the fact that Milo has this long history
of saying thinly veiled anti-semitic
things and transphobic things etc and
the right didn't care it's almost like
okay well now that he's saying it's okay
or not a bad thing for 28 year olds to
have sex with thirteen-year-old and by
the way what's this thing called consent
anyway now all of a sudden it's too much
for some on the right including the
American Conservative Union which runs
the CPAC conference but the fact that
all that other stuff happened and they
didn't care actually tells us a lot
about the American right as well
okay so main takeaway for for me is
lived by criticizing identity politics
and now all of a sudden turns out
identity politics was the only thing
that made him interesting to the right
because they could say hey look at this
gay guy who agrees with Trump and
doesn't believe that you know things
that feminism is cancer as he would
famously say etc etc so live by identity
politics I guess die by identity
politics I'm curious though if people in
the chat want to comment on whether they
think this is the end of Milo's career
or not feel free to comment and I don't
I don't know unless this boils over into
even more of a story I don't know how
much I'm going to talk
about it and you know I've known Milo
loosely casually for many years I on the
show today I basically had three direct
interactions with with Milo many years
ago before the and for people saying
David he quit already I started the
stream off by saying yes he is resigned
from Breitbart but the question is is
his career as sort of like a guy
speaking about politics in public over
years ago Milo was scheduled to be on
the David Pakman show and we were going
to talk about trolling online trolling
of all things and we had the interview
scheduled confirmed it with him he did
not write back and on the day of he did
what we call a no call no show which is
he's just not on skype at the
agreed-upon time he doesn't communicate
that he needs to reschedule just doesn't
show up eventually I think it was a
couple days later responded that he had
been ill and wasn't able to let me know
that he wouldn't be available a couple
years later gamergate happens I have
Milo on the program to talk about
gamergate related stuff we also talked a
little bit about his views on
transgenderism which he believes is a
mental or psychiatric disorder and that
interview did pretty well and then after
that he would every once in a while
tweet about content related to gamergate
that we did there were some interviews I
did that he liked some interviews I did
that he didn't like and that's basically
been it I tried to have him back on the
program maybe six months ago didn't
write back I guess he's probably and I'm
not saying this sarcastically he
probably became too big for the show and
had other other stuff to do and that was
sort of the last that I heard from Milo
and you know on the one hand there's a
contingent of my audience who really
doesn't care about Milo at all and tells
me that at the same time there's a
contingent in my audience who clearly is
interested in Milo because I get emails
all the time about it right now in our
reddit discussion forum on the front
page there are one let's see that and
there's a lot of Milo threads which I
have not started this is our audience we
have one two three
four five six seven seven threads seven
of the top 25 threads right now at david
pakman.com slash reddit which by the way
i encourage you to subscribe to our
about my low so clearly some people in
our audience are interested all right
okay so that's it as far as the the my
low stuff is concerned right now i do
want to say a big thank you to amit
gamble jr who just signed up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership this is mostly this is the
primary source of funding for the david
pakman show every day you have me
hosting and pat producing and noah doing
segment research and the moderators on
reddit and our interns everybody is
working to produce this show and it's
all mostly funded by membership so check
it out david pakman.com slash membership
we do have a major discount coupon code
which is I voted 17 and you can use that
code to get 40% off and that's all all
with peace and love I have no problem
with people using the discount code so
big thank you to Emmet Gable jr. who
just signed up okay tomorrow on the show
here's something interesting over the
last several weeks I did a few stories
about whether Donald Trump can read all
right and obviously I don't think Donald
Trump literally can't read I think that
his reading is of sort of diminished
capacity and he's not really reading at
the level you would imagine an educated
wealthy adult would be able to read at
the story the stories have done really
really well eight nine million views in
total across the different platforms and
different clips that we did but a number
of French media outlets have picked up
on the stories about whether Donald
Trump can read and I'm going to be
playing some of the clips and there is a
very it's a great clip from a program
called say vu in France where they play
some of my clip and they actually have
like a side-by-side so the panel is
there's cameras on the panel watching my
clip and their reactions are hilarious
and they have a smiling picture of me
the big screen behind them so I'm gonna
play some of those clips for you
tomorrow and for somebody correcting me
and saying it's set de vous no it's not
it's a play on words it's literally just
the letter C in any case this is not
really a show about about French and a
few different French viewers letting me
know about this which is great and I
appreciate so we'll talk about that
tomorrow on the show also you might
remember that before he was inaugurated
and really even before he was elected
but also before he was inaugurated
Donald Trump talked about how he won't
be taking vacations he won't be taking a
presidential salary he won't really be
leaving the White House etc etc etc and
as it turns out Donald Trump has been
taking vacations basically every single
weekend almost every single weekend
since being inaugurated and he has since
spent more tab well let me correct that
Trump hasn't really spent anything
taxpayers have spent more during Donald
Trump's first month as president than
they did during President Obama's entire
first year as president okay and we're
gonna be digging into the numbers
tomorrow and again it's super critical
on a number of levels number one
president Trump would criticize
President Obama for taking vacations
hypocritical number two President Trump
claims to be from the party of fiscal
conservatism and he is the guy spending
in one month what President Obama spent
in a year on vacations and number three
direct contradiction to what Trump
himself said he would do which was not
take vacations hardly ever leave the
White House etc etc etc okay so we're
going to be talking about that on the
program tomorrow before I continue with
that on that note big thank you to Jason
Meyer Jason Meyer just signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership with
the coupon code
I voted 17 and he now gets all of the
great member benefits including if you
normally watch like the 3 to 5 minute
clips on YouTube members get the full
hour show the entire one hour show minus
the 10 minutes of commercials as one
long video no waiting for our short
clips to publish
you get the entire thing usually around
4 p.m. Eastern as a member we also do an
entire additional show called the bonus
show just for our paid subscribers and
members get that and Jason Meyer now who
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership with coupon code
I voted 17 gets all that stuff for 40%
off okay
Isaiah Rowe Isaiah Rowe has sent a
five-dollar super chat saying what
Democratic ticket do you think could
best defeat Trump come 2020 I'm glad
that you asked this not because I want
to answer it specifically but because it
is important to realize that we
shouldn't be focusing on that right now
and I say this with total peace and love
by the way that's not a leaky patch on
my ceiling that's a speaker I say this
with total peace and love
we have 2017 we have two governor's
races to focus on we have the 2018
midterms to focus on we have the
preparation for the 2020 census and so
much other stuff going on right this is
not the time to think about the 2020
ticket for the Democrats and I would
actually argue we can't know today who
the best candidates would be for the
2020 Democratic ticket so I would
actually not think about that right now
I would focus on the other things that
that are going on there's really a lot
that we can think about thank you before
I move on to Robert gunto Robert gum toe
has just signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership also using the coupon
code
I voted 17 Robert opting for the yearly
membership which makes membership only 3
bucks a month Jason Meyer opting for the
monthly membership which makes the
membership three dollars and 60 cents
per month the coupon code I voted 17
works for all memberships okay also
tomorrow this is such a weird thing we
this is it we had so many stories to
deal with today that this was relegated
to do tomorrow we have there's pictures
of people that were onstage behind Trump
at this at this press conference or a
rally that he did in Florida okay and
they're holding signs that say
wacks for Trump 2020 and they were put
up on stage
apparently the Trump team didn't realize
that these are extremist lunatics and
they they they went up on stage and held
up these signs and when you go to the
website blacks for Trump 2020 and I'm
actually going to try to pull it up
right now blacks for Trump 2020 when you
try to go to the website it redirects to
another site or at least it did now it
doesn't seem to be redirecting it's a
total conspiracy nut web site and it
seemed that the Trump team had no idea
whatsoever that they were promoting
absolute and utter insanity and it
appears as though now that website
doesn't redirect anymore no it does it
still redirects to honest fact comm and
it is absolutely and utterly insane and
it's once again poor preparation from
the Trump team my guess is they were
like hey black people at one point we
were polling statistically 0% in Ohio
among black people if black people show
up we've got to put him on stage and
they did and it was absolute and total
nuttiness and we'll be talking about
that on the program tomorrow Brody
Andrew Mulligan has sent a $2 super chat
saying advice for progressives and
action plans for 2017
yeah so we've been outlining this on the
program and I am advising a combination
of number one staying on top of what
elections there are and there are two
gubernatorial elections that are
happening in 2017 they are I believe
Virginia and one other which is escaping
me right now on New Jersey Virginia and
New Jersey okay so progressives can get
involved there whether it's financially
or as it ramps up phone banking or
whatever the case may be and we also
need to be working at the local level
this is an area where Republicans crush
progressives and this doesn't matter
whether we're talking about actual
Democrats
or just the more progressive option in a
Republican primary there are also local
elections where party designation
doesn't exist it's just you're not
running with a party designation but we
can figure out as voters who's the more
progressive candidate there are many
opportunities to start working at the
local level and if you want to
understand why Republicans control so
many elections at the state level then
you need to look at what is happening
with state senators house represent a
state representatives remember that
lunatic that I used to interview with
some frequency a former Navy chaplain
Gordon Klingenschmitt he was a state
representative in Colorado for some time
which is insane I mean we're talking
about a guy who believes that you can
exercise not exercise but exercise the
gay out of someone and he was actually
elected in Colorado because it's not
that difficult in many of these
districts to get yourself elected you've
got some incumbent who's basically been
riding incumbency in the power of
incumbency for a very long time and you
can make it happen okay you can make it
happen at the state level let's go
through a couple Super chats stuff has
sent a twenty Mexican peso message just
saying greetings from Mexico well thank
you very very nice to hear from you
storage has sent a to Australian dollar
super chat saying consider doing a
segment on effective altruism okay I
will make a note of that right now
because that sounds like an interesting
idea to look into
I will check into that after the chat so
a lot happening there in the chat let me
say a major major thank you to two new
David Pakman show members Jacob ball who
has signed up with the coupon code I
voted 17 at david pakman.com slash
membership as well as clarence pen who
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership both opting for the yearly
membership which works out to just three
bucks a month that's effectively half of
the normal price okay so I voted 17
you can use the coupon code as much as
you want also here's another story I'm
going to be dealing with tomorrow
there's a really interesting article
called Trump wasn't a real CEO no wonder
his White House is disorganized and this
is from the Washington Post and I
encourage you to to check it out and it
makes a number of interesting points
about you know Donald Trump had a number
of preconceived notions coming in about
what it's like to be president and part
of that included the idea that he's just
going to be able to do whatever you want
sort of the idea of absolute power as
president of the United States and as we
mostly know I know that there are some
trolls in the chat who you know would be
likely to call me a [ __ ] or make
anti-semitic comments maybe they don't
realize it but most of our reasonable
followers probably realize this running
a corporation is not like running the
government and and so we've seen Donald
Trump frustrated by the reality that he
can't run the government like he ran a
business what this Washington Post
article is actually saying is that there
is not really a good track record of
Trump being CEO in other words Trump was
kind of a messy CEO and other people
were really making a lot of those
decisions and that we're seeing that
reflected in many ways in what's going
on in the Trump administration and sort
of part of the chaos is not that things
are going so-called wrong for Trump it's
just that this is how Trump runs it
right and that that's just exactly what
we would expect so we'll be talking
about that on the show tomorrow there's
a ton of other stories and this is sort
of a little bit of behind the scenes in
terms of what our production process is
I have right now 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 other possible stories for
tomorrow and this doesn't even include
what will inevitably happen at 3:00 a.m.
tonight that I'll wake up to tomorrow in
the morning we only have time for 7 to 8
stories on the show so I don't actually
know what
we'll be on the program today we could
talk about there's an interesting story
that the Trump administration wants to
change how the trade deficit is
calculated and you can imagine Donald
Trump has made a big deal out of how he
is going to fix the trade deficit with
Mexico and it seems that one possible
way to fix it that he's come up with is
just to change how you define the trade
deficit and this is so hypocritical all
during the Obama White House we heard
from Republicans
we can't trust unemployment numbers
under Obama because he's messing with
the numbers of course the reality is
that unemployment numbers have been
measured in the exact same way for a
long time and it's a matter of are we
looking at the u3 are we looking at the
u6 etc now all of a sudden Donald Trump
actually actually wants to change how we
measure an economic indicator that of
the trade deficit clearly clearly to
make it easier for him to argue that he
has made America great again with with
regard to the trade deficit so this this
is I read a piece by the co-founder of
RealClearPolitics today and we talked
about it on the bonus show where he said
everything can't be a scandal with Trump
because if everything is a scandal
nothing is a scandal there's a sort of
desensitizing to what's going on and
some people in the chat are talking
about this how do we decide what to
focus on right I did a story today and I
hope you'll take a look at it which is
called Donald Trump is the perfect straw
man because truly all of the crazy stuff
that Donald Trump is doing is taking
attention away from really really bad
stuff that Republicans in the House and
Senate are doing and this relates to our
environment this relates to so many
different things that are just happening
unnoticed because of what's going on
with Donald Trump okay so a little bit
of a preview of what's going to be going
on tomorrow let me thank a lot of people
in the chat saying they've received
their David Pakman show coffee recently
and that they are loving it I've not
received a one negative review about
David Pakman show coffee
people are people are loving it I'm
gonna do some video soon in my kitchen
of me actually brewing up some of the
coffee we've got an espresso blend and
we also have a drip coffee blend if you
have your own coffee grinder you can get
it whole bean if you want it all the way
down to a Turkish coffee grind you can
do that it's all at david pakman.com
slash gear and yes we have a coffee
partnership with blue fire coffee
roasters Patrick Maloney from blue fire
Coffee Roasters is roasting the coffee I
went out there it's in Hope Dale
Massachusetts about 40 40 to 300 minutes
from Boston depending on rush-hour
traffic and it is roasted and shipped to
you it is delivered fresh it is
absolutely fantastic and you can check
that out at david pakman.com slash gear
this is not big coffee by the way a lot
of people saying Oh David sold out too
big coffee sounding like Alex Jones but
indeed it is not big coffee it's quite
the opposite it's Patrick and a very
very small team that are roasting the
coffee for us okay Carol Ann Newsom has
sent a five-dollar super chat saying I
think the publicans won't rain in Trump
because they want to see how far he
pushes the line thoughts you're sort of
suggesting Carol that there's sort of a
curiosity from Republicans about what
might it be like if we just let Donald
Trump do absolutely whatever he wants
how crazy could it get I think that
there's a different reason that
Republicans may not reign in Donald
Trump number one
Trump's approval rating is still roughly
in the 40-ish percent range okay at that
percentage it's probably still useful to
Republicans to not publicly denounce
Donald Trump so that they don't risk
being alienated during the re-election
campaign for every single House seat
which is up for reelection every two
years in 2018 if Trump goes down to into
the low 30s or even 20s then I think you
will see more Republicans distancing
there's also the another idea which is
Republicans may be giving Trump enough
rope to hang himself so that then they
can
not necessarily impeach him but
basically create a de facto situation
where he ends up sort of being forced to
resign and that's another idea
five-dollar super chat from BW 85 BW 85
saying have you listened to Sam Harris's
latest podcast with Republican David
drum I don't know if that's actually
David drum or you mean David Frum I'm
not sure discussing Trump if not I
recommend it to you and everyone I have
not seen that or heard it rather I've
not listened to much of Sam Harris's
podcast but it sounds interesting and
some people in the chatter saying that
it's that it's worth checking out okay
thank you to a bunch of new members we
have our our I wonder if this is the
same Luke Vargas that I interviewed on
the program today Luke Vargas was on the
show today and we have a new member
named Luke Vargas so thank you to Luke
Vargas thank you also - oh boy this is
now going to be tough
Xiao Jie you I hope I'm not butchering
that name I believe it's Zhao Zi Yu who
signed up with the 40% discount code
I voted 17 at david pakman.com slash
membership so big big thank-yous I don't
think I missed anybody there Isaiah Rho
is upping the ante sent a five-dollar
super chat earlier now sending a $10
super chat saying what do you think of
official historical agencies always
having Lincoln Washington and FDR as the
top three and now recently having Reagan
at 11th and Obama at 12th this is as
like top presidents I did see that list
I have a facebook friend who is obsessed
with presidential history and he often
does like his own top presidents thing
on Presidents Day and he pointed that
out listen I mean it's so hard at this
point to say what list of the top
presidents sort of makes sense
Washington you know there's bias to the
first and George Washington is the first
president we're going to be biased in
favor of and more likely to say George
Washington was one of the
presidents Lincoln for his involvement
with the Emancipation Proclamation in
the Civil War that's a huge thing so of
course it's very very common that
Abraham Lincoln shows up on those lists
FDR governed during World War two
governed longer than any other president
and also was responsible for the era
which included the baby boom and sort of
the the New Deal and so many other
aspects of society that we now sort of
take for granted as integral parts of
America of the fabric of America so it
sort of makes sense it once you get
beyond that I mean who can say at this
point 31 days after President Obama left
office that he's the 12th best president
and not the 13th or ninth I think it's a
very very little value truly so I don't
I don't make too much of it and I don't
really pay much attention to that either
because I I think that number one there
are a number of different cognitive
biases towards the first towards the
most famous towards the first
ex-president and of course President
Obama fits fits into that so I don't
really pay too much attention to that I
also think that historical context is
important the actions that would make
someone a good president in 1850 would
be very different than in 1950 and very
different than in 2017 and so it's also
really difficult to compare what does it
mean to be a a best president a top
president etc stability is something
that that is important employment is
important but you know yeah look think
about this we are undoubtedly heading
towards significant technological
unemployment technological unemployment
being as a result of technology jobs are
being destroyed it's very likely that we
are not going to have the automation job
killer problem solved as it grows in
terms of being an issue
so it's very likely that there's going
to be a period of time where our
unemployment rate on paper goes quite
high will it definitively be
representative of a so-called bad
president I don't know it's going to be
a totally unique historical circumstance
when it comes to technology in the past
has always created so many new
industries that the net job effect was a
creator rather than a destroyer were
beyond that now okay so I don't really
know I don't really know what's going to
happen with that what do you guys think
about me banning a few people from the
chat I mean there's some people that I
haven't been looking at it for a while
and there's people that are just
absolutely trolling here and just really
really annoying I have to think about
the entire moderation thing right now we
only have 564 people on the livestream
and it's already going pretty wild and
when we've had a thousand people on
these live streams that have just done
randomly it is unbearable what is going
on in that chat and I know people want
to use it the counter to this is some of
the trolls just want attention and by
doing anything even now by talking about
it they it seems like it's almost like a
sexually arousing thing for some of
these trolls quite frankly and it's sad
it really is sad that this is how they
get off it fires people up and maybe
it's better just to ignore them and the
truth is if these live streams are going
to get up to hopefully they'll grow from
five hundred to a thousand to fifteen
hundred to two thousand people live I
don't even know that the chat will be
usable I mean I genuinely don't I know
there's a feature which is like slowed
down the chat which I think doesn't let
the same person post more than once
every 60 seconds or something like that
maybe that would be something to turn on
but I don't know maybe maybe we need to
get our some moderators or something
like that the problem is I just kind of
do these when I feel like it so it's
hard to have moderators just waiting for
me to connect to YouTube but we'll work
on that okay Schulz bot has sent a
five-dollar super chat saying Russian
involvement in Syria Russian and Trump
collusion and anti-muslim sentiment oil
refugee hysteria are there some bigger
picture
issues here well I've been talking about
this for a while the bigger picture
issues in terms of Russian involvement
are and and there's a really good
interview on our channel with Molly
McHugh and she talks about this we have
to go beyond the specific micro action
that Russia is involved in okay and
really think more broadly about what the
goals are and if you go back to there's
writings from the 90s from Russia about
geopolitics and what they point out
quite accurately I would say is that the
real way to gain sort of a momentum and
power and a powerful positioning with
regard to the United States is cause
chaos create events which make people
doubt whether the United States is
trustworthy whether the United States
sort of has it together and I think that
that's the broader goal of Russia's
intervention here if Donald Trump leads
to the reduction of sanctions on Russia
great I'm sure that they absolutely love
it however if it just creates chaos and
causes people to doubt whether the
United States is really the player on
the world stage that some people would
assume them to be under Donald Trump
then that's really the broader goal and
that that's something longer-term that
Russia may be wanting okay we've got a
bunch of different super chats here
things are exploding
let's see rest in peace Abu Laila says
what are your thoughts on the YPG and
Syria do you think that the US will
eventually betray them to appease Turkey
because of their links to the PKK I've
been studying this and I'm not ready to
take a position on it yet I think that
your instinct is very very interesting
which is that the United States has a
long track record of taking one side
internationally when it sort of seems to
make sense at the time and then
completely reversing that this also
involves giving weapons to people who
then we ultimately end up going after
because they used our own weapons
against
right a lot of this stuff has backfired
on the US and sometimes it's sometimes
sort of taking the loyalty aspect out of
it you can still make a pretty good
geopolitical assessment of why why that
that might be done okay we have another
super chat from Felipe Garcia who says
if when and if do you see Obama
returning into the political fray and
when is it a good idea for him to return
I hope that President Obama is having a
nice time windsurfing with Sir Richard
Branson or whatever it was that he was
doing right but I hope he gets reinvade
he left office with a really high
approval rating and that's something
that I hope he doesn't squander and it
would be great to see him rien volved
sooner than later I think that he
absolutely would be able to get people
catalyzed and activated in a serious
manner if he were to reappear very very
soon but you know what he's probably
glad that he's done Isaiah Rose sending
a $35 super chat record super chat that
we've ever had which one of trumps
cabinet picks thus far would you say
I've been the absolute worst and are the
most dangerous Wow that is really hard
to say I mean that there's one issue
here that I don't think as being
discussed in terms of any of the cabinet
picks which is which ones are truly
independent and which are basically just
puppets for Trump Trump may well be a
Russian puppet and a lot of these
cabinet members may not exactly be
independent thinkers and thinking about
the fact that it's Trump you have to
assume that there have been
conversations behind the scenes like for
example listen we're interested in mr.
Trump mister president Trump is
interested in you for this position but
you would need to sort of agree to X Y &
Z preconditions right the idea of these
preconditions and so I think it's to be
determined whose most dangerous I think
the Flynn stuff Flynn clearly was
compromised right he was clearly
compromised if not by Russia itself by
his own delusions of
grander in terms of lying not only to
Mike Pence but also we've now found out
lying to the FBI about the conversations
he had with the Russian ambassador with
regard to sanctions Martha Stewart went
to prison for lying to investigators FBI
investigators about personal stock
investments Michael Flynn allegedly lied
as we found out today two FBI
investigators about issues of national
sovereignty and security and and the
violation of the the idea of the one
president at a time policy talking about
sanctions as the unconfirmed selection
for national security advisor for a yet
unconfirmed uh not addressed n't he
usually huge hugely dangerous in what's
gone on so far okay Jason Meyer has sent
a five-dollar super chat what do you
think the chances are that our country
will be a dictatorship and or invaded or
controlled by foreign power okay
dictatorship by its very definition I
think is very unlikely invaded by a
foreign power in a military sense I
think is very very unlikely and
controlled by a foreign power you could
make the argument that a lot of what
Donald Trump has been doing is already
being controlled by a foreign power so I
think that the chances of that are
incredibly high it may already be
happening okay
oh we have a twenty dollar super chat
from Jacob ball what are your thoughts
on the French election do you think
lepen could win if she did would that
make a frecks it likely what do you
think that would mean for the EU okay I
really really I I love France
I love French culture I've had some of
the best vacations I've ever had in
France and part of what it would I
associate with France is not being what
what it would be under marine lepen
so I think that it is not the most
likely thing that marine lepen is going
to win but after seeing what happened
with Donald Trump in the United States I
absolutely would not write it off and I
think that it was a mistake that was
made in the United States to just write
off
president Trump altogether and you know
I partially guilty of this as well I did
not think that Donald Trump was going to
win
and I think if we've learned anything
from the election of Trump it is don't
write off don't write off that marine
lepen could win although I agree by and
large with the polling which is that you
are not going to see marine lepen win in
France okay
I've gotten distracted talking politics
and I did not realize that we have a new
david pakman show member big big thank
you to Kelly good Kelly good who has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership we have the coupon code
I voted 17 it is available to you
anytime and thank yous and shout outs to
people who sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership during a live stream
forthcoming ok so that that that will
continue to anybody that signs up there
ok a couple of questions about my
thoughts on the entire bill maher Milo
in appleís interview and so on the
regular show today we dealt with mostly
the Milo you na police pedophilia
scandal that's going on which got him
uninvited to CPAC which got his book
deal cancelled for which he received a
quarter million dollar advance and he
has since resigned from Breitbart where
he was some kind of editor or something
like that okay so we dealt with that
earlier I only mentioned a little bit
the Bill Maher appearance I found the
Bill Maher appearance interesting and
somewhat troubling in a sense in the
sense that I am NOT someone who is
against interviewing people with
outrageous views I do it on my program I
think that there is absolutely no
problem with interviewing people with
extremist views people you disagree with
et cetera but the context has to be if
you want to be sort of thinking and
respectable person that you think their
ideas are absolutely in totally nuts and
there were some comments that Bill Maher
made which I think at one point I
remember that he sort of likened Milo to
Christopher Hitchens in some way and I
still don't understand what kind of
harebrained interpret a of analogy he
was trying to make I thought that that
was that was sort of
odd and concerning I also thought that I
got you know two of the three panelists
plus bill maher said some cumbrous the
combination of go F yourself or F you to
Milo and although it was entertaining
and funny I think that that only further
strengthens the idea that Milo is the
victim
people are already throwing around the
entire drunken peasants thing was a hit
job and you know I am truly concerned
that there is going to be blowback from
this now increasingly when you get into
pedophilia it does get more and more
difficult to find people to sort of say
hey we love what you do forget about the
pedophilia comments we want to hire you
to do X Y & Z I don't know exactly who
it would be
I really don't but I I worry that there
is going to be some victimization
complex that may end up benefiting Milo
in in some way shape or form so I don't
know and I know that there are people in
the chat who disagree with me I do want
to say that Larry Wilmore who was one of
the people who said go after yourself
during the thing whatever I'm not
offended by that right I don't I don't
care I think it's helped tell people to
go F themselves it's not an argument but
it's III don't have any problem with it
whatsoever Larry Wilmore my impression
of Larry Wilmore was significantly
strengthened significantly strengthened
by his appearance on that panel I
thought he was absolutely fantastic I
thought that he was there and rebutting
so many of the things that Milo you
Napoles was saying would more than just
go after yourself and the other person I
thought was great
his name is escaping me but I put him on
my people to invite for an interview
list
Malcolm Nance Malcom Nance was the guy
on the far left of the panel so not the
right wing nut who was sitting on the
right and not Larry Wilmore but the
third guy I thought that he was
absolutely brilliant in terms of talking
of explaining why those who seek to
write off the entire Russia story just
genuinely don't know what the hell
they're
talking about he was really really good
and I'm gonna reach out to him
hopefully tomorrow and we're booked
pretty far out right now on the show but
I'm looking forward to inviting him on
the show and hope that we will have him
on the show along those lines we have
some really good interviews on the
program today we had Luke Vargas who was
just on the chat and watching the stream
we had Luke Vargas join us from Mexico
City talked about what's going on there
in in Mexico in terms of the potential
Trump sanctions tariffs etc etc economic
impacts and that was a really great
interview that will be it's on today's
podcast t v-- show radio show and the
stand-alone youtube clip we'll be going
up soon tomorrow we'll be speaking to
Bill o Goolsbee bill Oglesby is an
expert on gerrymandering and we're going
to talk about what is gerrymandering how
did it happen how is it how skewed is it
towards Republicans right now
then on Wednesday no on wait a second do
these dates make sense twenty-third okay
something maybe got messed up in the
scheduling in any case starting on
starting on Thursday we'll be speaking
to stiff Stefan or Stephen diyanet about
sugar addiction and obesity and diet and
a bunch of really interesting stuff on
Monday we'll have Mike Papantonio on the
show he just settled a major major case
of huge corporate wrongdoing and we're
going to talk about that with Mike
Papantonio we'll be speaking later next
week to Marcelo gleiser who is a
professor and also a Brazilian guy of
all things go figure and we'll be
talking to him about whether science
knows right from wrong that's something
that Sam Harris has spoken on we'll be
talking about it with Professor Marcelo
gleiser
we also have have a Cathy O'Neill
scheduled to be on the show she is known
to many in the audience as the math babe
I think her website is math babe org yes
it is so we're going to be having Cathy
O'Neill on the program we're gonna be
having Ronald Fry on Ronald Fry is a
very interesting guy military veteran
who actually lived in the Middle East
and and sort of did a different type
political diplomacy which is very very
interesting we're also going to be
speaking to Professor Matthew Liao
about the neuroscience of morality in
other words what how does morality
relate to activity in the brain and I
think that that's going to be absolutely
absolutely fascinating so a lot of great
interviews coming up Lyle frapp ear or
frappe from Canada sending a $2.00 super
chat saying what do I think about the
Omarosa hiring I think it is absolutely
insane and ridiculous truly and some
people saying this is Trump trying to
pretend that he's a friend of black
people or whatever I don't even care
about that I really don't care about
that it is just absolutely absurd and
she has struck me as one of the most
off-putting people that that has come
out of The Apprentice not that I know
that many people who have come out of
the apprentice and I think it's
absolutely an utterly deplorable
membership program mostly funded by
membership you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership there is a
coupon code you can use for a 40%
discount that coupon code is I voted 17
I've voted 17 gives you 40% off and
indeed Chris Ward has just signed up
although opting to pay full price and
not using that coupon code but by all
means
I voted 17 is the coupon code you can
use to get to 40% discount off of
membership and it's absolutely
extraordinary also Christina Escobedo
Christina Eska bet just now signing
signing up using the coupon code
I voted 17 so a lot of people signing up
a sort of a normal amount of David
Kookmin you're a [ __ ] and this is fake
and used type comments in the chat today
a little bit lighter on anti-semitism
which can be refreshing that that
absolutely can be refreshing often it's
the anti-semitic stuff that really goes
crazy and so that's nice thank you for
people will look to people who slightly
laid off calling me a [ __ ] and on that
note we're gonna wrap up this livestream
I'll do another one very very soon hope
you
to the show tomorrow